lately we've seen many Hollywood stars
challenging traditional gender fashion
norms and taking a more gender fluid
approach to style on red carpets take
pose star Billy Porter for example Billy
made headlines when he walked the Golden
Globe Awards red carpet
earlier this year wearing a floral
embroidered suit with a hot pink line
cake but it was his look at the 91st
Academy Awards that caused controversy
Billy wore a custom Christian Siriano
velvet tuxedo ballgown many applauded
Billy's look while others were outraged
and felt it was a hit too black
masculinity the following day Billy
spoke to The Associated Press about
toxic masculinity and said if you don't
like it go somewhere else you don't have
to look it's not about you I don't
understand why my putting on a dress
causes this much strife in your life I
don't either Billy when speaking to
vogue Billy felt he needed to clarify
something saying I'm not a drag queen of
a man in a dress simple Ezra Miller is
another star who is using fashion as an
incredible form of self-expression Ezra
who identifies as non-binary told The
Hollywood Reporter in their 2018 cover
story I don't identify as a man I don't
identify as a woman I barely identify as
a human in 2018 Ezra also did this
incredible photo shoot for Playboy
showcasing some stunning looks there's
an importance to the application of
ideologies of freedom and how you secure
space for nonconformity and to enforce
individualism you know what I mean to be
the person who you are
American Horror Story Apocalypse Star
Cody fern is also forgetting pass a red
carpet fashion norms a 20-19 Golden
Globe Awards
Cody wore a gender-fluid look which
included a sheer shirt which got praise
from both the New York Times and Vanity
Fair dad here this is Who I am
beautiful boys star Timothy sha'lame is
one of Hollywood's new leading actors
and along with his fame Timothy is
taking fashion risks and I'm here for
who can forget this harness or fine a
bib that he warded this year's Golden
Globe Awards while appearing on Ellen
she commended him on his fashion choices
I love the way you dress I think you're
like I mean every time you just have
such great style and you were the
coolest thing to the Globes it was
fantastic and people thought you were
wearing a harness of some yeah no I
thought I thought it was a bib they told
me it was a bib and I'd have friends
send me a thing that yeah like sex
dungeon culture is a thing where you
wear harnesses haha so that got a lot of
pickup
I wasn't I I didn't do it for that
reason but oh yeah anyway you always
look so good
following in Timothy's footsteps Black
Panther star Michael B Jordan wore what
Louie Vuitton called a novelty bib to
the 2019 SAG Awards speaking about his
choice Michael reportedly told variety
why not it was just like okay I'm gonna
do it what are you going with us Irish
actor Robert Sheehan who's currently
starring in the Umbrella Academy is
another example of an actor being
unafraid of fashion and expressing
himself this is my nicest outfit Robert
has been an ally for the LGBTQ community
for a long time and back in 2015 he
posted a video to Twitter urging
everyone to vote in favor of gay
marriage if you vote no
you're saying that gay people shouldn't
have the same rights as straight people
and you're basically homophobia
so vote yes when asked if he ever
questioned his own sexuality Robert told
Hot Press I think it would be
irresponsible not to question it I had a
couple of experiences when I was younger
with dudes where I tried it experimented
to see if it did anything for me and it
didn't love his honesty having stars
like Robert Timothy Cody and Billy all
expressing themselves through fashion is
encouraging to us not to fear gender
fluidity or the rise of gender neutral
fashion each of them are pushing the
boundaries of gender red carpet fashion
norms and helping to keep the
conversation going
look fashion is meant to be fun it can
be humorous or serious playful or dark
subtle or over-the-top like it or not
fashion says a lot about who we are as
individuals what do you think of gender
fluid fashion
did you like Billy's ballgown who are
some of your favorite stars who are
challenging gender fashion norms do you
have a huge crush on Ezra Miller like I
do let me know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
you